i'm curious for you claire i think it's
been i would say a little bit of a
moment since you've kind of done
something a little more period like this
so i'm just curious what drew you to the
role of cora and what made her an
appealing character to take on
um
well i mean yes she's she's of a
different time but actually she feels
incredibly
vital and contemporary um and she's
just
um
very
alive right uh
she's
kind of spilling over with enthusiasm
and uh eagerness and
um uh
you know and she had been
abused and repressed and but but when
you know she's
um released from that
um
um that kind of gilded cage that she'd
been held hostage
uh
she
she rises to the surface
almost immediately and and i and i just
found the playing of that to be
really
um
really enjoyable and
um
kind of
kind of
fascinating and fun and i love
i love uh all the different
relationships that she she gets to have
and and and how
um
love is
imagined and explored and articulated
through all of these um different
relationships and and that you know
her her connection to martha is as
critical as it is to well you know i i i
really appreciated that speaking of well
tom your character is someone i think
who feels a sense of duty not only to
his family but to the village you know
where he
lives how does korra's arrival um kind
of challenge his world
in in
almost every way
um
cora is bright and curious
and sophisticated and
um
and has no fear of questions
and
will is initially
careful about
korra's curiosity specifically in
in the essex serpent
for will the s the the rumor or the
superstition that this ancient winged
dragon that is swimming beneath the
waters of the estuary
is is going to destabilize the mental
well-being of
of his parishioners and create enormous
anxiety
and
he's trying to help everyone stay calm
um
but i think korra ins
invigorates and inspires in him
another kind of
intellectual curiosity and
they spark off one another and begin a
friendship that's grounded in
in um
ideas and
exploration
and
[Music]
and it throws him off center in every
way i would love to talk about where you
filmed this series because i think the
location of the show
you know essex really feels like its own
character in a lot of ways and the mood
that it lends to this premise and the
story for you both how do you feel
it lent more authenticity to the show or
maybe even kind of enhanced your own
performance in getting to film in these
locations
well i mean it was very striking it was
very beautiful and it was very wet
um but no it's true i mean so much of
the story is about the environment and
about
um
you know the stirring
quality of nature which kind of
transcends both
um religion and science you know it's
it's that's the um
it's the sublime right that they both
are
um
you know
kind of
uh
enraptured with you know and and um
yeah uh so so it was it's a critical
part of of the story
um but yeah it
was uh definitely um
an undertaking
yeah it was very windy
it was very windy and very wet yes but
it was it was sort of elemental and
evocative and uh
and sometimes
sometimes just you just had to be in the
landscape and
and be part of it and and um sometimes
the landscape was working with
with the story
but occasionally very beautiful and i
know i
i uh i loved i loved all of it i loved
the intensity of it
um
not having to
supply with my imagination that's right
i mean nothing was simulated
really
very little was created imposed
you know there was something wonderful
about that something else i think such
an important element to this show the
costumes are fabulous clara i think you
probably have the most outfits in which
the the fantastic design really gets
to be shown off um i'd love for you to
talk about how cora's journey as a
character is kind of reflected in her
costuming and and the changes that we
see her under undergo through the series
like as her as her outfits sort of
change too
jane our costume designer was amazingly
gifted um and she did so much of my job
for me
uh
and i took sort of endless inspiration
from what i found myself wearing
um but no i think she she really
articulated visually so much of cora's
um
uh
uh
trajectory
and uh
you know and also it was it
did it was a great service to me
because
you know when she's in london and she's
in that restricted space
that's her
the the that is um kind of really
reinforced by what she's wearing and
conversely when she's in essex you know
the clothes are much more forgiving and
she can
literally exhale um so that you know
that was all a great gift but yeah no
the the
um the aesthetics of the show i think
are
really fantastic your characters are
definitely i would say philosophically
opposed when it comes to the existence
of this serpent and whether or not it's
real but i am curious outside of your
characters would you be a skeptic or a
believer
in the essex serpent in real life
i'd be an optimistic skeptic
which is to say
they just say i'd be open to the idea
that there might it might be there right
maybe that's what cora occupies
well i mean i i don't think i would
until it was disproved
i don't mind the unknown
especially in the water
um
it's an odd thing to say i mean
uh
the the humility of not knowing that the
humility created by not knowing
and i think being able to just live
there is a is a brave thing
yeah i mean i think
cora
is
desperate to
finally
have a chance to figure out who
she is
that's that that had been denied her for
a long time so all that digging of the
earth is just a helpful way for her to
start doing that more internally so it's
really about that for her that's all the
time i have but thank you so much for
taking the time to sit and talk with me
about the show
you